[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je vais raccourcir les points
de chez Revlon
pour donner un petit peu de volume là au
niveau de la frangipane ok passe le main
il y a pas de problème avec un potentiel
merci alors non c'est pas mal mais je
sais pas en fait
mais on est content de la revendre
non mais c'est vrai
en ce moment j'ai pris beaucoup de kilos
c'est à cause de vous aussi parce que
faut savoir pour les tester qui nous
regardent qu'à chaque fois qu'on fait
des records de gens Cyril très
généreusement offre pas à tout le bureau
sauf que tous les jours cette année ça
va coûterait une tonne et du coup ça se
voit je vais arrêter ça d'ailleurs non
c'est très bien c'est très bien c'est un
acquis Cyril on va commencer avec le il
y a quelques minutes vous avez fait les
temps de parole des chroniqueurs
n'hésitez pas hein pendant la chronique
on le verra après merci on peut avoir le
classement des statistiques des
chroniqueurs s'il vous plaît qu'est-ce
que tu n'as pas à partir de là
avec le nombre de fois vous me l'avez
dit à mon avis
alors ça c'est c'est le classement des
chroniqueurs c'est c'est une séquence
qui vous permet chaque semaine de voir
un peu où vous mettez votre oseille
alors cette séquence elle est préparée
par Zakaria notre stagiaire star
national faut savoir que bah du coup il
est stagiaire et évidemment bah il gagne
pas des sommes mirobolantes du coup bah
certains chroniqueurs en ont profité
pour le sudoyer pour le Coran pour ce
classement était invalidé Cyril arrête
non
[Musique]
je me disais aussi fêter mais c'est pas
mais tu es vraiment qu'une merde
je suis sûr que c'est toi on parlez
comme ça
et horrible
[Musique]
il reste comme ça
cette
sanctionner
tu seras sanctionné
de 6 à 7
[Applaudissements]
h30
est-ce que à mon avis je vais peut-être
pouvoir en faire deux ou trouver
quelqu'un d'autre puisque Guillaume
Genton a triché
[Applaudissements]
lui aussi a triché je vous propose de
regarder lui aussi il y a des méthodes
de voyou et après Cyril prend des
sanctions
[Musique]
j'aime bien c'est pour les pas mal drôle
pour un pull
non mais toi de toute façon
tu es devenu affreux
tu es venu à l'affreux personnage oui
vraiment que j'aurais fait ça
c'est pas possible trouver une autre
défense là ce n'est pas moi tu veux que
je te dis ça fait
éliminer très bien belle fille Mathieu
Sacha et Daniel
je l'avais dans le 6 à 7 on va faire un
carton sur les plus souvent
[Applaudissements]
vous savez c'est tout ce qui se passe
pendant les pubs pendant les offres
pendant les Magnéto et si Raymond avait
une femme là à l'heure actuelle c'est
pas sûr qu'il en est encore à la fin du
magnéto regarde
[Applaudissements]
personne pour se faire rire et ça c'est
fort
dans les zones dégradées
pendant 10 ans dans les hommes où elle
vient s'installer il quasiment plus
espèce de fourmis il est content de sa
blague et attention Mathieu Delormeau a
porté le virus de la boulardise sur le
plateau et c'est belahim qui a très vite
été contaminée
à gauche c'est un effort à droite tu vas
sur le bout là et le scoop de la semaine
c'est Cyril qui s'est enfin confié sur
sa vie privée
comme personne n'y croit
c'est le chroniqueur qui a la plus
grande carrière pourtant c'est celui qui
a le moins de charisme et qui est
qui
va rester debout
on continue avec Raymond love au mille
facettes livreur chroniqueur émetteur de
boules
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
une petite fortune
et encore vraiment lui c'est assez
discret quand il mate mais Bernard
Montiel lui c'est nikoumouk hein il y va
c'est chaud
Bernard
évidemment comme toutes les chansons qui
adorent Cyril il est connaît par cœur ou
presque c'est magnifique
avait les mots
alors en vrai on est médisants il la
connaît sur le bout des doigts la
chanson
[Musique]
le gros problème qu'on a sur ce magnéto
il porte un nom cérémon
c'était quoi le sujet le sujet c'était
de juger
inappropriée
j'ai regardé c'est la tenue était
inapproprié
de la variété
avant de repartir il faut savoir donc je
m'adresse là où tes spectateurs pendant
les pubs vous pensez peut-être que Cyril
bah au lycée fiche et bien sûr qu'il est
boulot boulot pas du tout il préfère
jouer et cette semaine c'est pas moi
arrête c'était le retour du fameux jeu
tu préfères tu préfères normalement ce
jeu on a le choix entre deux
propositions un peu relou
bien sûr
c'est un peu tout le contraire et ça un
peu plus drôle comme ça regardez quand
Matthieu Delormeau et Cyril tiennent un
jeu il faut participer tout le monde et
surtout il ne lâche plus le jeu
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tu as pas le choix sinon toute ta
famille
[Musique]
[Rires]
tout le monde veut sauter il est où le
piège
fais-le fais-le fais-le monsieur là
[Musique]
tu préfères coucher avec Daniel Moreau
[Rires]
en même temps enfin le truc en même
temps
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
il y a beaucoup de gens qui ont dit
Daniel Moreau voilà
tu dégages